ننتقل المشاهدين الان الى ملف الاحتجاجات
في ايران حيث تتواصل التظاهرات في مختلف
المدن واقمع السلطات ضد المحتاجين يشتد
لترتفع حصيله القتلى الى 419 على الاقل او
على اقل تقدير بينهم ستون طفلا
و ابي حسب مجموعات نشطاء حقوق الانسان في
ايران فقد تم اعتقال ما لا يقل عن 18,000
و170 متضاهرا وكانت 156 مدينه ايرانيه
مسرحا لمظاهرات مناهضه للنظام ففي العاصمه
طيران خرجت مظاهره في منطقه اقبلتان حيث
هو ردد المتظاهرون شعارات ضد النظام فيما
قام المحتجون باشعال النار في الطريق
بمنطقه ستار خان في المدينه وبعد فوزا
المنتخب الايراني لكره القدم على ويلز في
كاس العالم في قطر 2022
هتتاهل فرديس كار رجل الموت والدكتاتور
شعارات مؤيده للاعب كره القدم الكرديه
المعتقل غفوري